Modern cognitive neuroscience tells us that
our memories are about as reliable as as the
weatherman at your local news channel.
When a couple is asked How did you first meet?
they are lured into romanticized reflection.
They might recall locking eyes at a school
dance.
They might recall the night being just perfect…
despite the truth being far from it.
We don’t remember the spilled punch, the
stepped-on toes, or the stuh—stuh--stuh-stuttering.
We only remember the x’s and o’s.
Our memory doesn’t find the needle by sifting
through the haystack, but rather by lighting
a match and setting the barn ablaze until
all that remains is that small piece of silver,
shining through smoke.
In this way, our memories are our best friends
– they know exactly when to lie to us, feeding
us misinformation about the past to satisfy
ourselves in the present.
Because if humans were capable of writing
and recalling accurate personal accounts of
their history, our memoirs would be stiff,
un-marketable literature.
And when a book gets boring, we tend to tap
out.
Just the same, when our lives get monotonous,
we tend to give up.
So, we have our faulty, biased brains to thank
for our perceived happiness and fulfillment.
Our inaccurate memory systems consequently
help us hide trauma, contrive purpose, and
infuse unique importance into an otherwise
banal existence.
But let it be known, not all cerebral restructurings
are gifts from psychology.
Some are curses from SCPs.
Which of these two possibilities is more existentially
terrifying is up to you.
SCP-5040 is a nonexistent Japanese horror
film entitled "Tears of Blood", which spontaneously
manifests in human memories.
SCP-5040 is a master of persuasion.
Those affected by SCP-5040 will remember going
to see the film even when their supposed attendance
would contradict empirical evidence.
It manipulates the mind into unwavering faith.
While humans occasionally stumble upon the
self-awareness to question their recollection,
there are no documented instances of an individual
doubting this specific memory.
Somehow, beyond The Foundation’s understanding,
SCP-5040 manages to suspend the skepticism
of its victims.
They accept the memory as canon.
As brute fact.
Victims of SCP-5040 do not need a ticket stub
to know they had been to the theater, and
SCP-5040 afflictions can occur any place where
movies are shown.
It even transcends laws and navigates social
norms.
In cultures where its content would usually
be prohibited by regulations and frowned upon
by the public, it still inserts itself into
the memory of its prey.
And once that memory is planted, it’s an
event that can’t be forgotten.
Like the birth of your first child.
Like your favorite football team winning the
Super Bowl.
Like the employee number you punch in and
out of work every day for the rest of your
life.
It stamps itself into the forefront of the
subject’s brain, waving its arm, pleading
to be recognized, begging for attention.
Descriptions of the film are always similar
in nature, as are the circumstances and events
surrounding the viewing.
However, reports of SCP-5040's story and characters
are never fully consistent from one subject
to the next, and the film's setting, subplots,
character names, and much of the dialogue
are different for each viewer.
Whether this is SCP-5040’s intent or inadequacy
is unclear.
Casting also varies and appears largely arbitrary;
a broad variety of Japanese performers and
entertainment personalities - both living
and deceased - have been said to star in the
film, even when the actor in question has
no real-life associations with the horror
genre.
Imagine famous Japanese actor, Pat Morita,
better known as Mr. Miyagi from The Karate
Kid, being the lead in a horror film.
Despite the fact this would be a noticeably
strange casting decision, SCP-5040 would still
be taken seriously.
Despite any and all deviations from expectations
of the medium, SCP-5040 is seen as legitimate.
Kinks in its design are overlooked by the
viewer, similar to how our sleeping selves
most often don’t recognize we are dreaming
– even when we encounter flying horses,
friends with banana fingers, and leprechauns
playing pot-limit Omaha in Chris Hemsworth’s
basement.
This may be because, despite all its quirks,
the film's core is sturdy.
Its beginning, middle, and end are always
in agreement.
It doesn’t stray from Robert Mckee's universal
structure of Story.
Not even the sick and twisted M. Night Shyamalan
himself could have created a cinematic experience
quite like this.
After conducting more than three hundred interviews,
researchers have constructed a detailed synopsis
of SCP-5040's most consistent story elements
and the most common sequence of events associated
with the viewer's memory of their screening
attendance.
There is no matinee with this movie.
Screenings always begin at sunset.
If there are obstacles standing in the way
of a subject's attendance, SCP-5040 will see
them removed.
Dentist appointments, drinks with a friend,
a long-procrastinated date with the treadmill,
all these commitments for that day and time
will be pushed down the subject’s list of
priorities, making way for the movie.
They will learn that their plans have been
canceled or resolved one way or another.
The dentist's office burned to the ground.
Your friend is suddenly sober.
The model of treadmills at your gym has been
recalled.
Somehow, someway, time is freed up.
And when life is kind enough to offer respite
from personal and social obligations, it is
modern humans’ instinct to sit down and
veg out.
At this moment, the subjects decide to see
a movie at a nearby theater.
Upon arrival, the theater looks to be an entity
in its own right.
Long lines of patrons are like limbs extending
from its center box office.
Bright, blocky letters forming the film’s
title run across the marquee like a cheap
tattoo.
It’s madness.
A frenzied crowd gathers at the box office,
pushing and shoving, clawing at the glass
partition for a ticket.
The entire theater has been reserved for this
special event: a one-time-only screening of
a rare, critically acclaimed film.
Drawn in by the excitement, the subject indulges
their curiosity and gets in line for a ticket.
Admission is entirely free.
But is it actually free?
Or has the cost just not declared itself?
When the subject reaches the auditorium, they
scan their eyes over the sea of people.
Heads emerge from the backs of almost every
seat.
They can only find one empty space, and they
have to shuffle like a crab to get past the
mass of other viewers.
In their seat, they notice that a large number
of people throughout the audience are wearing
disposable face masks.
The woman sitting next to the subject’s
right wears one such mask, as does the woman
on their left.
And before you think, “Well, that isn’t
so weird”, it’s important to note that
all of these accounts were taken years before
certain recent events.
Patrons continue to pack into the theater.
Despite every chair being filled, more and
more people enter.
The aisles become overflow seating.
Regulations of Max Occupancy are dismissed.
In the darkness of the room, all that can
be clearly seen are shapes.
The rectangle that is the screen.
The hundreds of circles that are the heads
of the audience.
But also there’s a shape that feels misplaced.
What appears to be the letter “P” sticks
up from the crowd.
A thin line with a bulge protruding from the
top.
The specificity of its origin is difficult
to define.
But once the subject’s eyes adjust to the
dark, they notice it’s an IV pole carrying
a bag of unknown fluid.
However, there is no clear indication of who
it is connected to.
Furthermore, they notice one of the masked
audience members is wearing a hospital gown.
There is little time to assess any of these
strange visuals, because there are no trailers
or advertisements before the film.
As soon as the audience is settled into whatever
space they might find temporarily habitable,
the theater goes silent and the film begins.
The film opens with the female protagonist
going about mundane activities in her day-to-day
life.
A phone call interrupts her.
It’s an unknown party, who tells her that
a loved one has been hospitalized, for one
reason or another.
The protagonist drops what she’s doing to
accept the call to action.
On her way to the hospital, however, she is
attacked by a male assailant and loses consciousness.
The protagonist wakes up in a fog, unable
to make sense of her surroundings.
But the audience understands that wherever
she is, she’s in deep trouble.
She’s in a desolate and unfamiliar building
with her arms and legs bound.
She is accompanied by a number of other female
captives, some of whom still remain seemingly
unconscious or possibly dead.
The women briefly discuss their strategy to
escape, but they are interrupted when the
kidnapper appears.
Descriptions of hairstyle, eye color, and
wardrobe would fall short in showing us who
this character really is.
Instead, his swift and decisive actions do
the talking.
He sees one of the women crying and kills
her without hesitation.
The kidnapper reveals to the women the code
he intended to operate under.
He would release the captives after 24 hours,
but only under the condition that they do
not cry.
During the film, the kidnapper demonstrates
various forms of physical and psychological
torture on the group of women.
Despite their best efforts, the captives are
unable to hold back their tears, and one by
one they are murdered until only the protagonist
remains.
Frustrated by the protagonist's unremarkable
resolve, the kidnapper takes more extreme
measures, increasing the violence and intensity
of her torture.
However, the protagonist is not one to be
messed with.
Despite being tormented, she seems in control
of the situation.
She doesn’t succumb to the traditional dynamics
of torture.
Even while on the wrong end of the bat, she
isn’t afraid to swing.
She fights back how she can.
She mocks and insults her captive.
And it's then that she finds his weakness.
Although a physically empowering villain,
he is emotionally fragile.
Her grit frustrates him, causing him to lose
focus and become noticeably rattled.
As the protagonist continues to weaken her
kidnapper with words, the subject in the audience
notices what seems to be a slight echo in
the dialogue.
They look up to see if something is wrong
with the speakers.
They even wonder if this is a stylistic decision
made by the director.
But then they notice where it is coming from.
They eventually realize that the two masked
women sitting beside them are quietly repeating
every line of dialogue as it occurs.
Their lips moving causes their masks to shake
softly.
With each word, the air from their whispers
blows the cloth away from their mouth, only
for the mask to collapse back in when the
syllable is completed.
If the subject looks even closer, they will
see that the lower half of the women's masks
are saturated with saliva.
Things don’t get any more pleasant when
the subject shifts their gaze down the women’s
body.
Just near their waists, their hands are clasped
together so tightly that their fingernails
are digging into their skin.
They tremble and fidget as if having taken
on the burden of the world’s anxiety; and
no medication can calm them down.
Fingernails dig deeper into their skin, drawing
blood and foreshadowing the film’s finale.
At the film's climax, the kidnapper approaches
the protagonist with a double edge razor blade
and announces that even if she is freed, she
will spend the rest of her life horribly disfigured.
This leads to an argument between the two,
the subtext of which alludes to themes such
as the nature of inner and outer beauty, the
value of women in society, and the societal
stigma against expressions of vulnerability.
The argument on the surface, however, does
not sound sophisticated or profound.
There is no consolation for a fight having
emotional depths.
At the end of the day, the blows will always
feel more physical than intellectual.
Eventually, the kidnapper loses patience,
and grabs the protagonist by the shoulders
and slams her to the floor.
He reaches out his hands and grabs her by
the face.
The subject’s attention is again pulled
from the screen when they hear groaning from
every direction.
It sounds like the accumulative grumblings
of every chore in human history ever moaned
and groaned about.
These wordless hums fill the theater with
a sense of worry and uneasiness, so much so
that the subject feels the room getting smaller
as the air polluted with angst grows thicker.
As the subject brings their eyes back to the
film, they see the kidnapper gripping the
protagonist's lower lip between his thumb
and forefinger, squeezing tight as to pop
her lip like a balloon.
The kidnapper then takes the razor blade to
the victim’s lips.
He pauses to mock the protagonist.
And while he does this, blinded by pride and
arrogance, she jolts into action, grabbing
the razor right out of his hands with her
teeth.
She follows up her burglary with assault.
Her neck stabs forward and in a blur, she
stabs the kidnappers' eyes out.
It happens in an instant.
The kidnapper has no time to react.
Blood spills from his face.
Screams pour out of his mouth.
During this time, the protagonist maneuvers
the razor into her fingers.
She hacks away at her bindings, but they are
stubborn and resist her sawing.
The battle continues, and the kidnapper is
able to tear off the victim’s lips entirely.
She looks like a monster now.
As the kidnapper smiles and celebrates his
wrongdoings, the protagonist finishes freeing
herself and slits the kidnapper's throat with
the razor.
The protagonist locates the exit and scrabbles
toward it as the kidnapper bleeds to death
on the cold, hard floor.
The protagonist then speaks her final words.
Due to her injuries, her voice is muffled
and raspy.
She bears down and calmly speaks.
One last time, she mocks the kidnapper, telling
him that he "cried tears of blood" and therefore
had to die according to his own rules.
During this climax, it is reported that subjects
experience a sense of dread unique to any
other terror ever felt.
Strangely, the feeling appeared not to correspond
to the scene in the film at all.
It is a feeling entirely separate from the
viewing experience, as if for a moment the
subject is taken out of the moment in time
and transported to a realm composed only of
fear and anxiety.
But just as quickly as they left, they returned.
The Foundation sees it worth mentioning that
this peculiar moment happens to occur during
the film’s most clearly recalled scene.
While descriptions of violence vary from one
viewer to the next, the climax is unshakable
in its consistency.
This is further evidence that SCP-5040 has
a core foundation that remains intact.
False memories are given validity by our peers.
When we tell a story, the inaccuracies are
often the best parts.
The exaggerated drama.
The rearranged sequence of events.
The jokes you thought of only in retrospect
but weaved into later accounts.
While a storyteller knows when to lie, a good
storyteller knows how not to get caught.
SCP-5040 captivates its audience, but it seems
to know how much it can get away with.
By providing a consistent, objective truth
– a climax that is reported the same across
all accounts – SCP-5040 insists, even if
only briefly, on being a credible film, not
just a random sequence of 24 frames per second.
Eyes back to the screen, the film abruptly
cuts to an unspecified point in the future.
Now wearing a face mask to hide her disfigured
mouth, no different than the ones seen worn
in theater, the protagonist walks down the
street to her apartment, indifferent to the
crowd of paparazzi that follows her.
It’s clear that this is now just a part
of her life.
The lights flash on her face.
When she reaches her bedroom, the protagonist
slowly pulls down her mask.
Face free from cloth, she stares at herself
in the mirror.
It is silent.
What she sees is less notable than what she
doesn’t.
The lower portion of her face is gone.
She focuses on only that.
It’s hard to know if she will ever see into
her own eyes again.
Her gaze might forever be fixed on what she
can’t get back.
And through those eyes that long to see more,
she sheds a single tear.
Over the course of several minutes, her weeping
gradually builds into frenzied sobs and shrieks.
It can first be misinterpreted as bad acting,
a case of doing too much.
But as the crying carries onward, it’s understood
that the horror in her wallowing is all too
real.
The film cuts to black and the credits roll,
but the sound of the protagonist's cries continue
to play with no other audio until the credit
reel ends, and even then, in silence, it’s
hard to say if she ever stopped crying.
Audience members remain silent after the movie
ends, exchanging only whispers as they exit
the theater.
Feet step over small red puddles and stains
on the theater floor as if they are sticky
puddles of soda.
Those who remain past this point experience
an escalating feeling of unwelcomeness, until
sitting and staying is more physically demanding
than getting up and walking out.
Some experiences will stay with you forever,
even if they never actually happened.
Now go check out “SCP-592 - Inaccurate History
Book” and “SCP-2030 - Laugh Is Fun”
for more media that’ll stick in your brain
forever!